of all the adjectives to describe
democracy which stands for
giving the people the right to choose
who's in charge the man who stood up to
take over the white house
didn't pick fair stable or strong
democracy sometimes messy it sometimes
requires a little patience as well
but that patience has been rewarded now
for more than 240 years
with a system of government governance
that's been the envy of the world
just messy or it's just gotten way too
messy
in his country we have received reports
of many irregularities
we believe that there are dead voters
that have been counted
this is fraud this is absolute fraud
trump campaign says they're going to
court
the biden campaign says it's ready for
court fights protests by trump
supporters and a series of vote fraud
allegations
by the president himself trump will go
to war
over this election and that is dangerous
for this country
there is quite a list of things
appearing as cracks in the system
take the mail in voting in times of
covet when the nation was meant to rely
on it
at one point the postal service warned
it couldn't cope the
president flushed the method altogether
saying it would lead to a rigged poll
if you read some of these pieces there
have been
plenty of such the media has been
questioning the confidence
in u.s democracy europe's been watching
the mess in the wings with
raised eyebrows the deep polarization of
america should be a warning for europe
we are successful because we breach
differences between countries and
peoples
so we benefit together if we lose the
ability to compromise
our democracies are in danger what's
happening in america does not quite
correspond to the democratic culture we
know from the united states
it's important that the result is then
accepted by everyone
it's easy to be a winner but sometimes
it's hard to be a loser
trump's late night speech puts a
question mark over his possible second
term in office
it is hard to imagine what this second
term would look like
when the president directly called for
the abolition of the rules of democracy
his call to stop counting votes is a
blow to the essence of american
democracy
here's a voice of concern from allies
japan
we can say for the united states to get
into turmoil and confusion because of
the election
is a minus for its allies and
like-minded countries
but perhaps the most fascinating thing
to observe is the sneer by
america's foes after so many times
washington told
them how wrong things are with their
elections
what a spectacle one says this is the
most fraudulent
election in u.s history who says that
the president who is currently in office
his rival says trump intends to rig the
election
this is how u.s elections and u.s
democracy are
we do not interfere in the internal
affairs of the united states
and we hate it when they pretend to give
lessons in democracy to the world
disputes chaos and refusal of election
results
were supposed to only take place in
developing states
things have changed all this have
occurred in the u.s
which is no longer synonymous with a
stable civilized and consensus-based
society
now just for a giggle let me read out
one tweet
it's an official one country a calls on
country b's leaders to show
commitment to the democratic process and
rule of law
we urge all parties groups and
individuals to engage in
inclusive dialogue to find peaceful
solutions to their disagreements
to heal national divisions full stop
it's a tweet by the u.s embassy country
a
in ivory coast country b from november
4th oh the irony
there's a reason a lot of western
european nations stopped doing mail-in
ballots a long time ago france stopped
in 1975 because the process
is rife with fraud and i have to tell
you i think it's incumbent upon the
trump campaign
to say al gore took 37 days to litigate
florida we're going to go litigate and
we're going to demand recount some are
going to be automatic obviously in
georgia but in wisconsin in michigan
in pennsylvania in nevada and arizona we
want to get
to where we have free and fair elections
where every legal vote is counted in a
trustworthy and transparent way the
american people deserve it i was wishing
and hoping that last night trump was
going to look into the camera and say
i'm demanding a free and fair election
that the american people can trust not
for myself
but for you because you deserve it and i
think the scary thing in all of this is
at the end of the day no matter who
ultimately wins half of the population
of america is going to think the
election has been stolen
that is a very dangerous place for us to
be in as a country